I've heard that the floor asks for
shrubs to be put in the comment areas
yeah right we will not let this lie
because like when obviously we you know
put in some rocks too
oh interesting all rocks are my friends
I didn't know
citizens of the world I'm Dave Rubin
this is the Reuben report it's January
9th of the Year 2023 we are live
streaming on Rumble and on YouTube if
you have not subscribed already at
rumble.com
reubenport please go ahead and do that
and if you want to join us after the
show for the post game wrap-up where I
read comments answer questions I can be
corrected if I make an error all sorts
of stuff you can go to
reubenreport.locals.com the team is
fired up and in a good mood today I can
tell I feel we have a very very tight
show for you and we're going to be
talking about
sanity versus the machine the machine is
Just Gonna Keep Coming the sensorious
nature of the machine the lying the BS
all of that stuff it is not going to
stop I think if you watch this show you
get that it is going to continue to come
at us both culturally and politically
through people that we should have
gotten rid of a long time ago whether
they're CNN anchors or New York Times
journalists or bureaucrats like Anthony
fauci but there are some glimmers of
hope so you guys know I like my hope at
the end of the show we're going to get
you to some hope but before we do hope
I'm about to show you
what I think might be the most unfunny
thing in the history of the world okay
we've shown you unfunny things on this
program we've shown you video of Stephen
Colbert before we've shown you a video
of The Daily Show we've shown you a
video of other late night programs
trying to be funny but Jimmy Fallon who
is the host of The Tonight Show The Once
great Tonight Show The Tonight Show of
Jack Parr and Johnny Carson and Jay Leno
uh he is the host of The Tonight Show
now and uh he did a little song and
dance because apparently there's a new
covid variant coming and I saw this over
the weekend on the Twitter and I thought
it's so horrific it is so so crushing it
is so the exact perfect example of what
these corporate sellout nothings push on
all of us endlessly that is the
mainstream machine that I have to share
it with my audience which is a little
sadistic of me if you think about it
Jimmy Fallon
it was Alpha Ben Delta van Omar chronix
[Music]
another brand of public 19 has arrived
it's a new strain but it isn't the same
sounds more like Elon Musk his name
[Music]
UB40 who sings Red Red Wine put on your
map when you're inside a facility it
could be a robot from a Star Wars
Trilogy
Point 1.5
how long do you think I can hold that
face
all right I know you didn't laugh at
that and I'm sorry we had to start the
show with that
um but that is that is a corporate
channel right meaning NBC this is a
giant corporation that puts on a show at
I think it's at 11 30 every night it's
The Tonight Show has been on for
70 years I mean really since the
beginning of Television you know
and it was funny it was it was meant
really so people could go to bed with
sort of a little bit of the news of the
day right with a little bit of a
monologue and maybe an interesting
conversation actually one of the things
that I've been doing lately
um and there's really nothing on
television that I want to watch anymore
because our cultural norms are so
backwards I watch old Johnny Carson
tonight shows I've also been watching
the old roasts remember the old roasts
with Dean Martin I've been watching a
lot of those when comedy was actually
funny and there was in a reverence and
Hollywood actually was kind of cool
something like that but the reason that
I'm showing you this video is you have
to understand that all of the stuff that
the machine gives us is a complete farce
now first off there is this what is it
xbb 1.5 okay it doesn't even matter it
just does not matter what this thing is
he talks about Alpha and Delta and
Omicron they they stopped the world for
about two and a half years and they'd
love to stop the world again and by the
way some masks are coming back in
various blue States will get that in a
little bit but if they believed
that this was so serious that all of
these people have died and it was so
horrific and it was worse it was worth
closing schools and ruining children's
education and destroying the economy and
making sure that Grandma as she was
dying couldn't be seen by her
grandchildren all of those things do you
think Jimmy Kimmel would be singing
about it
do you think he'd be singing about it I
had Phoenix check as that video was
playing Jimmy Kimmel has about 50
employees on the program about 10
writers so 10 writers came up with that
plus Jimmy himself I suppose
and that's what they put out there
pandering nonsensical
BS like endless BS but why would they do
it why would they want you to be afraid
of covet again right like you survived
the Alpha and the Delta and the Omicron
why do they want you to be afraid of
this thing why do they not want to let
it go could it have something to do with
money could it have something to do with
sponsors would it be possible
I don't know maybe it's just Monday and
I ate a lot over the weekend I'm just
thinking crazy things you know what I
mean I was hanging out with the kids
you know I'm seeing the world in a new
way could it possibly be the giant
corporations pay other giant
corporations to promote their stuff
whether it's good for you or not could
that possibly be and could we even have
videotape proving just that
Good Morning America is brought to you
by Pfizer CBS healthwatch sponsored by
Pfizer Anderson Cooper 360. brought to
you by Pfizer ABC News Nightline brought
to you by Pfizer making a difference
brought to you by Pfizer CNN tonight
brought to you by Pfizer early start
brought to you by Pfizer Friday night on
Aaron Burnett out front brought to you
by Pfizer This Week With George
Stephanopoulos is brought to you by
Pfizer this weather report brought to
you by Pfizer today's countdown to the
Royal Wedding is brought to you by
Pfizer and now with CBS sports update
brought to you by Pfizer Meet the Press
data download brought to you by Pfizer
this portion of CBS This Morning
sponsored by Pfizer on how to find the
hidden sugars in the American Family
diet sponsored by Pfizer
foreign for the record the Reuben report
is brought to you by this glass of water
I bought the glass at Target and it's
Florida natural tap
if you think Jimmy Fallon is horrible
and again 50 people are paid that that
show it generates millions and millions
of dollars for a giant Corporation to
keep you afraid while it is paid by the
very companies that are forcing you to
be injected and stay home and all of
that stuff but if you think he's bad
at least he hasn't been in blackface as
far as I know has Jimmy Fallon ever been
in backface we know we got Jimmy Kimmel
he's always in blackface but then
there's this other guy Stephen Colbert
right and Stephen Colbert because I know
many of you are thinking about it
because we showed it to you a while back
and we're about to show it to you again
I'm just bludgeoning people this morning
here's Stephen Colbert with his little
dance number because I guess legally if
you're sold out and I mean sold out
s-o-l-d and also s-o-u-l-e-d if you're
sold out uh late night television host
you have to dance and sing about
vaccines and debase yourself in front of
the American public
foreign
[Music]
vaccine
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look at those clapping feels
what is going on and this is comedy this
is comedy and you know we all know damn
well that if Donald Trump had been
president still at that point when that
originally aired and he was pushing for
the vaccines at that point that they
would have all been against the vaccines
right so and now it's like well where
are your dance numbers Jimmy Fallon and
Stephen Colbert where are your dance
numbers about all of the vaccine
injuries the people that are having
heart problems the young men that are
dying in very very bizarre rates we'll
get to that in just a moment nothing
about that because you guys always give
the machine what it wants and what the
machine wants is people to be afraid and
as you guys know politics is Downstream
of culture and part of the tension that
we're having right now is that fewer and
fewer people are tuning into these
things right like I got I got three
young people in this room you guys are
all in your mid and mid-20s into your
early 30s you're an old veteran at this
point Connor 30 years old uh does anyone
you guys know watch The Tonight Show did
the kids talk about The Tonight Show
when you guys having your coffee in the
morning or your Hot Pockets or what are
kids having in Hot Pockets what do kids
have it Pop-Tarts Pop-Tarts I don't need
Hot Pockets anyway the point is that
they are losing control of the narrative
and that's why they're becoming more
hysterical at the exact same time that
really is it because people aren't
watching that stuff they're watching
shows like this people or were just
outside maybe taking walks breathing
fresh air but mainstream culture and
mainstream entertainment they are
collapsing by the minute and the people
who just feed the machine they're
becoming less useful to the machine it's
what I was always saying about Brian
stelter remember Brian stelter he was
always saying the exact thing that the
machine wanted Donald Trump said very
fine people on both sides Russia
collusion Brett Kavanaugh is a serial
rapist he was always giving it what it
wants and then at some point the machine
says well we don't need you anymore
you're just useless and that's why he
doesn't have a subscription thing or his
own show anymore you got a gig at
Harvard but that's just the machine
protecting their own nobody actually
cared about Brian stelter but he was
part of the machine so people talked
about him it's the same thing sort of in
in the way I'm framing this around
Fallon and Colbert but these people who
give the machine what they want it
cannot end well for them and that's what
I was trying to discuss with Bill Maher
a couple months ago you may remember
this but isn't that crazy that you're
right that all the all the comics that
were supposed to put everybody to bed or
whatever it is they all went bananas
left I mean but these guys are terrible
like Kimmel to me is just [ __ ] you
may be friends with him I know a lot of
people
yeah like he's Colbert
yeah like those guys to me they're just
the worst sort of partisan nonsense you
want everybody but the good part of that
is we don't hide it like he doesn't like
me and I don't like him and we don't
deny it and we don't like it no but he's
nothing yeah he's nothing very
successful no no but he's just giving
the machine what it wants all the time
you giving you for my differences with
you I totally respect you he's well said
yeah giving the machine What It Wants I
wish I had thought of that phraseology
that's exactly right
I want to give Bill Maher a little
credit here because a week later on his
show and he was a little slow to it but
a week later after we had that
conversation on his show and we
obviously talked about much more and I
even got him to say that if Cali brought
lockdowns back and mandates and
everything else that he actually would
move to Florida that's a pretty big
concession for the you know the the gold
standard of liberalism in America here
is Bill Maher on his show one week later
uh talking about the pandemic and our
reaction and all the subsequent problems
now we're getting some information after
a while we have time for find out just
how bad the collateral damage has been
uh here's just a few cases the pandemic
erased two decades of progress in math
and reading see right away I got to say
this pisses me off I see these headlines
all the time the pandemic didn't do that
the way we handled the pandemic did that
the pandemic certainly was a thing
but let's not just say the pandemic
because it was not written in stone that
we had to handle it the way we did uh
ACT scores are the lowest in 30 years
um anxiety and depression way up the
body mass index uh increased doubled for
Kids 2 to 19. drug overdose overdose
deaths murder is way up inflation at a
40-year high domestic violence increased
um oh and my favorite car crashes they
couldn't figure this out like we're way
way way up and they're finally the I
love this this is the the expert said
you know what it is people just went
[ __ ] mental foreign
they just went nuts they're like I'm
home the [ __ ] kids are here all the
time my stupid husband is here all the
time I'm just gonna take it out on the
highway and they did
so that is good right it's good when
people and I know a lot of you and I I
when I talk about Bill Murray I always
get a lot of comments people are like
why are you still talking about him he's
never gonna get there he voted for all
Democrats last time around but but if
someone like him talking about some of
this stuff getting to the truth better
late than never right because he's
supporting as far as I can tell he's
supporting still a guy like avenuesome
who is still for all of these things or
at least did all of these things in the
past right
um but him talking about it waking up
some people is good but I want to bring
this back to the machine because there
are people who have been around forever
that try that basically threw away all
of their ideals in the middle of this
over the weekend I was watching uh
Arnold Schwarzenegger in the movie
Running Man the movie running man's
probably 1986 maybe we can check on that
something like that uh and at the
beginning of the movie they have like a
Star Wars style blurb and it takes place
in 2017 but it's 40 some odd years ago
talking about a dystopian future where
the government censors everybody and
free speech is under attack and they
arrest people and all of these things
for going against the system for caring
about freedom
and I was watching it and I was like
this and it's one of my favorite movies
by the way those those 80s
Schwarzenegger movies it's 87 actually
like their their Total Recall I love all
of those movies Terminator everything
else but I was watching it and I was
like wait a minute so that's what
Schwarzenegger was doing these cool
Sci-Fi movies about watching out for the
man watching you know making sure that
the machine didn't get you back in 1987.
how is he back in August of 2021
but I think people should know there's a
virus here it kills people and the only
way we prevent it is to get vaccinated
to wear masks to do social distancing
washing your hands all the time and not
just to think about well my freedom is
being kind of disturbed here no screw
your freedom because with freedom comes
applications and uh and have
responsibility
screw your freedom from the guy that was
like the 80s 90s action Superstar every
movie fighting for Freedom that was the
uh I suppose fictitious caricature or
character of our Arnold Schwarzenegger
uh but then if but you have to get vaxed
you have to social distance you have to
wear masks none of it worked none of it
worked it was all
illegitimate it was all pushed on us by
this machine that just wants more and
more of our freedoms and it's going to
keep coming now you'll see why I'm
telling you all I'm showing you some of
these old clips why am I uh showing you
these old clips because speaking of
screw your freedom here is Bill Gates
now Bill Gates as you know created
Microsoft in the 80s I always like to
talk about Microsoft Paint you could
click a button you could fill up a thing
you could do that little it was there
was that one that was like a cloud sort
of you could paint in like a cloud
formation remember that it was very very
exciting it also had tons of what is it
uh viruses that's right Microsoft
brought your PC home right in your house
you could have a computer there and then
you'd get pop-ups and viruses all day
very interesting that a guy who created
the operating software for our computers
and then viruses were getting in and now
he's very concerned about the viruses
that are hitting our bodies well over
the last couple days he was on Al
Jazeera which is a state-sponsored
Qatari news
he was over there talking about global
surveillance and the next pandemic which
is coming and oh don't worry guys
they've got better mRNA vaccines and
they're going to be injecting you with
them too why and how ready should we be
for the next pandemic
well governments are there to protect us
and so you know they have us practice
for earthquakes you know they have a
fire department with lots of full-time
people to stop fires
they have armies that are there to deal
with Wars but the pandemic is a disaster
that they didn't prepare for the actual
resources required to have a global
surveillance team to make better
diagnostic Technologies there's some
good uh Innovation the idea of improving
the vaccines so that they block
getting infection making them so they
last a long long time
it's amazing they're thinking about
making a vaccine that will block
infection they're they're gonna because
they're gonna get the scientists on it
they're gonna cancel lunch and they're
going to have a vaccine that vaccinates
that's what these people are up to man
he is like the devil incarnate he is
also as you guys know we've mentioned it
many times he is also the largest
Farmland owner in the United States
while he is pushing for you people to
eat bug slime out of a bucket while
you're locked in Zuckerberg's uh
metaverse over there and with some weird
electronic things snapped to your nuts
we'll I'll explain that in the next
tomorrow maybe a little further anyway
the whole thing is insane right these
people are just absolutely awful also
that line that he started with the
government is there to protect you
what's the line from Reagan right the
the scariest nine words in the English
language I'm from the government and I'm
here to help my God my God it's all
happening right in front of our eyes but
speaking in front of our eyes Anthony
fauci who uh lied about everything
across the board where the vaccine or
where the uh well where the vaccine came
from too uh but where the virus came
from where the vaccine came from masks
he lied about absolutely everything as
you know he has now stepped away so I
suppose he's now just a private citizen
he's not he's not uh Lord fauci anymore
uh but he's still doing the media rounds
and he talked about her he was asked
about the possible vaccine injury of
Demar Hamlin who of course is the
football player that passed out on the
field last week uh and you know a lot of
people were saying this seems like it is
probably
vaccine injury related because 95 of NFL
players were vaccinated we're hearing
all of this stuff about vaccine injuries
and heart problems and myocarditis and
much more so fauci was asked about that
I don't know if you saw it but on Monday
night football this week Demar Hamlin
player for the Buffalo Bills collapsed
on the field
you're not an NFL expert and you're not
an expert on any cardiovascular issues
the player might have had but what I
want to ask you about Dr fauci is
as I want to do in moments like that I
kept an eye on Twitter
and I can't tell you exactly how many
minutes transpired but it was less than
20.
before people on Twitter began to say
well clearly the vaccine caused his
seizure what that means major is that
yet again another conspiracy theory
complete nonsense is going to have some
people make a decision for themselves
and their family not to get vaccinated
which may cost them their lives as you
well know Dr fauci there is some shred
of evidence myocarditis was related to
vaccines it is a heart issue I'm not a
doctor you are that's a shred right of
evidence a very small shred right what
and explain how then this can get
conflicted of course in a very very rare
case
some of the MRNA vaccines can cause a
self-limiting
almost invariably benign
inflammatory response in the heart which
generally resolves in a very short
period of time it is very very rare
it's very very rare is that right these
heart problems it's very very rare
because you guys may remember about a
month and a half ago right before Elon
Musk got Twitter our Florida Surgeon
General Dr Joseph latipo was censored on
Twitter because he published well he
tweeted about a published report that
that they did related to young men and
vaccine injuries specifically about the
heart here's the here's the Tweet today
we released an analysis on covid-19 mRNA
vaccines the public needs to be aware of
this analysis showed an increased risk
of cardiac related death among eight
among men 18 to 39 Florida will not be
silent on the truth
just FYI guys in the paper that he
linked to That Was Then censored and
then uncensored finally there was an 84
increase in heart issues among young men
18 to 39 do you think that there might
be a connection there but he dismisses
that he dismisses that right he not only
dismisses it but if you even talk about
it you're a conspiracy theorist and
what's his name who's the who's the
interviewer there that's not is that
Major Garrett who is that guy the way he
frames everything like you're the good
guy fauci I'm not a doctor I'm just the
average [ __ ] can you explain everything
to me please but speaking of vaccines
and mandates and masks and young people
we knew it was coming we knew it was
coming and then I saw this this morning
masks are coming back from mlive.com
It's michiganlive.com News masks will
now be required while indoors in Ann
Arbor Public Schools from January 9th to
January 20th for all students staff and
visitors in order to combat a surge of
illnesses as students return from break
yes it is happening right now and I
would say to the people of Michigan
well not if you're someone watching this
and you're from Michigan because then I
have sympathy with you but I think you
should go but everyone else you voted
for Gretchen Whitmer again you did you
brought back the same governor who was
one of the worst you know you got your
Newsome you got your Kathy hochel you
got your Gretchen Whitmer the trifecta
of evil related to covid but you guys
re-elected
I was gonna I was gonna say the b word I
was going to say the b word I'll try
it's Monday you were you re-elected that
witch
that was good you re-elected that witch
and that's what you get here's Whitmer
back in September of 2020 uh and
listened to her when she's talking about
uh Bill Barr who was against these crazy
Federal lockdowns and everything else so
U.S should stay at home orders early in
the pandemic and you have not ruled out
issuing them again if there's a big jump
there the Attorney General Bill Barr
spoke out about that sort of order today
here's what he said
you know
putting a national lockdown stay-at-home
orders is like house arrest it's not
it's the it's you know other than
slavery which was a different kind of
restraint this is the greatest intrusion
on civil liberties in American history
greatest intrusion on civil liberties
and American history
what do you make of the comparison to
slavery
I mean I just think the Attorney General
was unhinged and it is deeply disturbing
that our chief law enforcement officer
is promulgating this kind of
craziness the fact of the matter is
um the the worst thing that we can do
for another American is to give them a
virus that could kill them that's the
biggest violation of our civil rights is
an Administration and a government that
is undermining our ability to protect
ourselves and our lives and our
livelihoods
first off he did not compare it to
slavery right he did not compare his
labor he was saying slavery was that
this is something else altogether okay
that's number one putting that aside for
a moment she's evil she's evil but the
people of Michigan voted her in so they
signaled to the evil woman can you do
more evil to us and that's why it will
come back in New York and it will come
back in Cali I have great sympathy for
any of you watching this that you're
there and
in Michigan or your kids are at an Ann
Arbor school and you don't want them in
this it's up to you right now it is up
to you to either take your kid out of
school or start homeschooling or leave
the state take your family and your
skills and your resources and your
goodness and your sense of community and
pride and and belief in America and
American exceptionalism whatever it
might be and move to a Freer place and
strengthen these places because these
people will not stop because they have
been given the signal via elections that
people want more and more and speaking
of a guy who will gladly bring all of
the evil back Gavin Newsom was
inaugurated last week because he got
reelected too and a protester a guy by
the name of Joshua Coleman he's at Josh
Bucky on the Twitter uh he was almost
arrested for peacefully protesting this
is a this this video and this is just
another perfect example you're never
going to see this on mainstream media
but you really should so he peacefully
protests you're going to see and then
watch what happens as the police chase
him down after and he just does an
absolutely great job of how you should
deal with true that perceived but true
Injustice
[Applause]
I I mean am I under arrest can I commit
a crime today but then I commit a crime
well I don't I don't think I need to say
my name unless unless I've committed a
crime or if I'm being charged with a
crime
[Music]
you're saying I'm being detained what
crime did I commit
what crime did I commit
am I free to go
um do you mind hanging tight for us I
would rather go if if am I free to go
[Music]
appreciate I appreciate you guys I
really do
that's how you deal with this now look I
don't want to make this about that
police officer but whoever told that
police officer that they should detain
this guy should be fired immediately I
get it it's California no one will get
fired whoever actually did it'll
probably be chief of police if not
Governor within the next four years but
they you see what they did there they
detained him they're asking him his name
they didn't know why they did it uh do I
have to stay here well we'd appreciate
if you just stand here what this is
Banana Republic level [ __ ] but whether
it's happening in Michigan or it's
happening in California it is going to
continue so if you live there good luck
with all of that
that really is where we're at on all of
this stuff and the more that we expose
it the more they'll double down on it
because they're so deep in the muck and
the mire that they can't come out of it
now you know what I mean they can't
crawl out of the pit of sarlacc and be
like boy I really did screw up that
whole thing uh so there is just more and
more information coming out on how the
government coordinated to silence people
related to covet so a journalist by the
name of David zweig he had a really long
extensive Twitter threat on on what's
going on here uh with the government and
big Tech I'm going to just read you
portions of it it was like a 30 uh tweet
long thread so we just picked some of
the highlights here the Twitter files
how Twitter rigged the covid debate here
we go by censoring info that was true
but inconvenient to US policy so here
are the highlights first by discrediting
doctors and other experts who disagreed
by suppressing ordinary users including
some sharing the CD scenes the cdc's own
data the United States gov government
pressured Twitter and other social media
platforms to elevate certain content and
suppress other content about covid-19 it
wasn't just Twitter the meetings with
the Trump White House were also attended
by Google Facebook Microsoft and others
so let's just be clear this was the
Trump White House too when the Biden
Administration took over one of their
first meeting requests with Twitter
Executives was on covid the focus was on
anti-vaxxer accounts especially Alex
Berenson in the summer of 2021 President
Biden said social media companies were
killing people for allowing vaccine
misinformation Berenson was suspended
hours after Biden's comments and kicked
off the platform the following month but
Twitter did suppress views many from
doctors and scientific experts that
conflicted with the official positions
of the White House as a result
legitimate findings and questions that
would have expanded the public debate
went missing inevitably dissent yet
legitimate content was labeled as
misinformation and the accounts of
doctors and others were suspended both
for tweeting opinions and demonstrably
true information
exhibit a Dr Martin koldorf an
epidemiologist at Harvard Medical School
tweeted views at odds with U.S Public
Health authorities and the American left
the political affiliation of nearly the
entire staff at Twitter No thinking that
everyone must be vaccinated is as
scientifically flawed as thinking that
nobody should covid vaccines are
important for older high-risk people and
their caretakers those with prior
natural infection do not need it nor
children
internal emails show an intent to action
by a moderator saying coldorf's tweet
violated the company's covid-19
misinformation policy and claimed he
shared false information after Twitter
took action koldor's tweet was slapped
with a misleading label and all replies
and likes were shut off throttling the
tweet's ability to be seen and shared by
many people the ostensible core function
of the platform okay then of course what
you know the the post-mortem of this is
that Elon Musk eventually buys Twitter
Alex berensen is back on Twitter Dr
Robert Malone and Dr Peter McCullough
are back on Twitter uh he is
systematically right now Elon Musk
getting rid of the content moderation
teams at Twitter he fired a whole bunch
more people just this past weekend who
were in charge of silencing people but
the fact is you really just need to know
this guys it kind of sucks to know
because it puts us in one of those
dystopia Ian Schwarzenegger movies from
the 80s the government without question
was pressuring social media companies to
silence you Outsourcing The Tyranny they
know they knew they couldn't show up to
your house right they couldn't send a
government agent to your house to say
stop saying that because it would have
been too much of an obvious violation of
your first amendment so what did they do
through emails and other pressure they
made sure that that these largely
lefties so they were in line with them
when it came to covid these largely
Lefty employees of Twitter would go
ahead and do the silencing themselves
but it gets even worse because this
really goes all the way up to the White
House and it really goes all the way up
to the elderly man pretending to be
President Joe Biden himself here's some
info from the Daily Caller the White
House pressed Facebook to censor Fox
News host Tucker Carlson for saying
vaccines don't work according to a
document least by Republican attorney
general Jeff Landry of Louisiana since
we've been on the phone the top post
about vaccines today is Tucker Carlson
saying they don't work yesterday it was
Tommy Lauren saying she won't take one
White House director of digital strategy
Rob Flaherty reportedly said in the
April 14 2021 email to an unidentified
Facebook employee which was posted on
Twitter by Landry you guys get this it
isn't that the government came to all of
the big tech people and said we are
going to arrest you if you don't silence
these people but by having these email
exchanges with them by saying you know
the number one tweet if you call up a
Twitter employee you know the number one
tweet is TWiT is uh Tucker Carlson
saying vaccines don't work the number
two tweet is Tommy lahren saying she's
not going to take vaccines well Tucker
basically turned out to be right and
Tommy Laren has every right not to take
vaccines just like you and just like me
reminder I had coveted about two and a
half weeks ago I was out playing
basketball the same day I'm not back
half the rest of my family had it some
younger some older they were all sick so
either I should be studied maybe fauci
would love to study me fauci would love
to put me in that thing where they lock
you down like the dog and then they put
your head and then they let the flesh
eating things eat your face up no no
fouchy you can't have me
all of this is to say because I know you
guys get it right you get that this
thing is happening so what's the chance
what's the chance that we have well
believe it or not the Republicans now
control the house okay so we didn't get
the Red Wave but the Republicans got the
house and uh McCarthy Kevin McCarthy
after 15 freaking votes he is finally
here's the numbers we got the numbers
for you uh as of what two days ago Kevin
McCarthy got 216 votes he is now the
House Majority Leader Hakeem Jeffries
the Democrat who's a complete nut bag
got 212. okay a couple others got zero
in present fine uh here's video of Kevin
McCarthy winning the vote
therefore the honorable Kevin McCarthy
of the State of California having
received a majority of the votes cast is
duly elected Speaker of the House of
Representatives
okay so what's interesting about this so
he gets in finally after 15 votes they
voted out for a couple days what's
really interesting about this is Trump
was backing McCarthy the whole time the
group of 20 who were against McCarthy
they're thought of as the most Trump
uh Republicans that there are this is
Lauren bobert Matt Gates chip Roy
meaning these are the guys that are
thought of as the trumpians so you have
Trump backing McCarthy and then the 20
guys going against McCarthy are all
thought of as Trump supporters so this
is some really interesting political
Dynamics here I said last week you can
check the videotape on this it's good to
have a little fighting who cares if we
don't have a leader for a couple days
who cares if we don't have a government
for a couple weeks it would be a
freaking pleasure if you ask me well one
of the guys that was holding out was
Chip Roy from Texas here he is on CNN
with Democrat activist Jake Tapper
explaining that yeah you know what some
fighting about this stuff is actually
pretty good well first of all you know
let's remember that a little temporary
conflict is necessary in this town in
order to stop this town from rolling
over the American people I don't think
anybody on either side of the aisle
could say with a straight face that they
think that Washington is doing uh good
work for the American people on a
regular basis and isn't broken uh it we
we have to work to fix this place and
look some of the tensions you saw on
display uh when we saw some of the you
know the interactions there between Mike
Rogers and macades uh you know some of
that is we need a little of that we need
a little of this sort of breaking the
glass in order to get us to the table in
orders to fight for the American people
and to change the way this place is
dysfunctional
yeah that's right so guess what those 20
uh Republicans who fought they got some
concessions out of McCarthy and you know
what McCarthy's first thing that he's
going to do now that he's House Majority
Leader you know what the Republicans are
going to do it's actually pretty
beautiful he already announced it
I know the night is late
but when we come back our very first
bill
will appeal the funding for 87 000 new
hours
thank you
maybe this is the chance right what do I
always say you don't have to be a
republican but you cannot be a Democrat
and the Republicans will probably fail
you I still believe they will probably
fail us but there is a chance here like
that's a great moment the guy comes in
right the first thing he says we are
going to get rid of 87
000 new IRS agents that's what these
lunatic Democrats were putting forth
they want to make sure they can find all
of your money right they can always find
enough money to give to Ukraine another
40 billion in that bananas 1.7 trillion
dollar spending but they want to just
find out how much money you sent to your
aunt on PayPal 87
000 agents to look into you they take
your money to pay people to look into
your finances and the the the you
applaud it not you them okay so it's a
good start so what else can you do in
McCarthy and I'll I'll hopefully sit
down with him and discuss this you know
know what go after fauci go after
Twitter go after this Administration if
if this is your opportunity right all
right I'm talking to you Kevin McCarthy
this is your opportunity these 20 most
of them came around and did end up
voting for you you've got a little juice
right now if we do not have free speech
in the United States we have nothing
else we know that the administration
pressured Twitter to take down tweets
and to silence Tucker Carlson that is a
violation of the First Amendment someone
in the white house has to be fired and
you know what I bet you you could figure
out an argument that it goes all the way
to the top in the email actually that
the uh that the that they've released
they talk about how Biden like this is
important to Biden that this information
that Tucker talking about vaccines uh
that it doesn't get out there so it
could go all the way to the top it
really could guys so that is what the
chance is Republicans I know you'll fail
us I'm not sitting here with Rosy
glasses I know you'll fail us I I don't
know why you'll fail us exactly you guys
tend to suck too you're a little bit
better but you suck in your own way and
by the way I mean this of course at the
federal level what we're running here in
in Florida is the most perfect happens
to be a republican operation that's
being run perfectly so I'm talking about
this obviously at the federal level but
there's a chance get rid of the IRS
agents figure out what's going on with
free speech let's find out who was doing
what related to January 6th and and this
Ray Epps guy like there's so many things
we can we can actually unfurl and get
back to something more honest
I know I'm a dreamer but I'm not the
only one uh ladies and gentlemen because
it is Monday it is me Monday over at the
Reuben report locals Community here's
the one I put up this morning the third
leech isn't working better give him
another booster leech you think history
repeats itself people yeah it does
that's right it does okay we are going
to continue with the post game wrap-up
show if I made any mistakes if you have
any thoughts on what I said any comments
any questions any queries you can let me
know right now we are going to keep the
post game show available for everybody
just jump over to
reubenreport.locals.com I believe the
the link to the specific post is right
down below uh we're gonna keep it open
for everybody for one more week this
will be the last week we're keeping it
open for everybody and then it will be
for subscribers only subscribers are the
only ones that can comment directly but
for now you can at least watch it's five
bucks a month or you get a couple months
free if you join us annually and you
help keep this show independent as you
know we are we are fully fully fully
independent Rumble us we're doing it
people
this is the future uh part one of my
interview by the way oh and you really
want to check this one out with Tulsi
gabbard we talk about all of this stuff
I taped it on Friday part one is up
today the full thing will be up on
locals today absolutely ad free and we
get into all the censorship stuff and
and I ask her you know a lot of a lot of
you guys who like Tulsi gabbard you're
more on the right but you like her and
she obviously left the Democrat Party
but one of the things that I see about
her often
is people are wary of her second
amendment stance I ask her directly
about that uh and a bunch more so you're
going to want to check that out uh we
leave you with a cold close and I will
see the locals people in about
42 seconds
while we're on this sort of stuff
you heard of the Pied Piper well my
dream Pied Piper had toilet paper one
sheet of the cheap kind yes and he took
that and he ripped out a creme brulee
and a little tiny pepper yes before he
ate a tree you didn't have that drink
yes I did nope okay you did not don't
tell me you did it's not true you didn't
never get to dream of the Pied Piper
eating a tree I mean
you're telling me you dream that too
I
wasn't as cool as my dream
[Music]